we turn to this developing story now a
woman's body was found floating in a
lake
up in the desert shores neighborhood
this morning it's near buffalo drive and
lake mead boulevard
hector mejia is live in the northwest
valley with an update on this
investigation hi hector what can you
tell us
hey there and authorities are not
suspecting foul play but neighbors tell
us the response was big enough to raise
concern around here we're told that just
after seven o'clock this morning someone
found
a body right here investigators on the
scene told us it was the body of a woman
found floating
over in that part of the lake we are in
the desert shores neighborhood near
regatta
and buffalo drives metro homicide
detectives did not find
anything that would indicate foul play
on the scene
for neighbors though this is a bit of a
mystery this is known as a quiet and
safe area
we talked with two people left stunned
after hearing about this happen
so close to home i lived literally right
over there they had probably a dozen
cop cars here this morning this was all
sectioned off they had the workers get
down from the trees so they could
do whatever they're doing i mean i i
haven't seen anything in this
investigation i walk around this lake
every day and i fished this lake right
here
and i mean i've just never seen anything
like this in the neighborhood this is a
very
quiet far from the strip far from life
that kind of area but then my second
reaction is maybe it has to do with
the covet and the situation a lot of
people are
very depressed
details from police about the
investigation are limited right now we
do not know how the body ended up in the
lake or how the woman died
we also do not know if she lived in the
area and we are expecting to learn the
name of the woman
from the clark county coroner's office
once family gets notification
reporting the northwest valley hector
mejia 8 news now